un masivo deslizamiento desde la ladera
de una montaña acabó enterrando a los
operarios de una mina al aire libre uno
de los seis supervivientes aclarado
desde el hospital que escucharon el
estruendo pero que no les dio tiempo de
completar la evacuación en las últimas
horas ha sabido que la misma compañía
había sido multada ya en el último año
por infracciones como rutas de acceso
inseguras al almacenamiento inadecuado y
escasa formación de los supervisores de
seguridad el accidente devuelve los
secos del pasado cuando las minas chinas
eran las más peligrosas del mundo y los
accidentes con decenas de Muertos eran
tan rutinarios que apenas eran recogidos
por la prensa en 2010 morían una media
de 7 mineros al día en China y su
mortalidad multiplicada por 47 La de
Estados Unidos el gobierno lo intentó
todo para ordenar una industria
atomizada en miles de pequeñas Minas
muchas de ellas ilegales y con escasas
de seguridad pero que eran protegidas
por los gobiernos locales Porque eran
una importante fuente de ingresos en las
provincias más pobres el gobierno
incluso llegó a aprobar una ley que
forzaba a los jefes de las explotaciones
a bajar a la mina para compartir los
riesgos y ahí afloró la picaresca china
al día siguiente muchos mineros fueron
ascendidos a jefes sin embargo todas las
medidas han conseguido mejorar muchísimo
el cuadro el año pasado murieron 240
mineros frente a los 2.600 de 15 años
atrás Es decir uno de cada 11